leeks the White House has been plagued
with leaks the real problem is that
there are people in Crump staff that are
really worried about the country so
they're leaking fundamentally that is
the problem and yes
Trump has no reputation for hiring good
people so maybe part of the problem is
he doesn't have the best people working
for him but Kellyanne Conway is thinking
about this as treat the symptom and not
the disease the adviser to the President
Kellyanne Conway said that the Justice
Department might consider using lie
detectors on Trump's own staff to figure
out who is doing the leaking here she is
on Fox and Friends certainly on Fox News
talking about it calling every person
and go ahead and run a lie detector on
why don't they do that well they may and
this is they may they may not there are
many different ways to discover who is
leaking for the West wing's a small
place eg TV agencies is relatively small
I think it's easier to figure out who's
leaking than some a real and the leakers
may realize but on this matter I want
there to be bipartisan outreach this is
just fascinating on multiple levels one
is that you would even consider
subjecting your own staff to lie
detector tests as a necessity to stop
leaks second lie detectors are
incredibly inaccurate if you trust a
polygraph you should check out the
former police officer Doug Williams who
has talked about how dangerous polygraph
tests are they're very accurate in
measuring sort of like general stress
levels but you can't really measure
complex cognitive activity like lying
through what's basically a stress
measurement anyway this is not a segment
about lie detectors per se but the
reality is that statistically they're
realistically there are probably many
leakers because the number and the broad
scope of the leak suggests this is not a
small problem
the recent transcript leaks for example
it's very likely that those transcripts
went through that with the conversations
with the Mexican and Australian leaders
they probably went through multiple
channels before before ultimately
getting to the media and it would be
relatively tricky to find the leakers
through lie detector tests and another
issue is I don't understand why everyone
in the administration is so worried
about leaks because Trump is causing a
lot of his problems by his tweets and
the things he says in national news
interviews most of the Russia
problem would not even exist were it not
for the constant leaks and things that
trumps I'm sorry for the constant tweets
and things Trump says during interview
and many times they'll just confirm
whatever the leaks alleged of them right
so it doesn't even really matter in the
end because they don't try to contest it
that's right and it's pretty telling too
how you know these White House staff
members they go into the job all Mogga
all like ready to go they're you know
fully in support of the president and
loyal to heavy historian and then they
get discouraged and realize that things
aren't going so swimmingly so they're
turning on their own people the only
good thing about that is that means
there's at least some people working for
Trump who are not so ideologically
committed to the Trump agenda and the
Trump cult cult of personality that they
can't realize how bad it's getting and
then there's also the distraction
element right which is that they can
never address the real issues so instead
they attack the leaking it could leak
that Trump said let's start killing
puppies I don't know and you hear leaks
are bad they're bad folks this is
America
Snowden running around Hillary wanted to
give him a medal Democrats are bad folks
in Korea they eat dogs Obama was a [ __ ]
cat guy he didn't even like dogs he was
all about cats I've directed Jeff
Sessions to investigate the leaks we're
talking about felonies here no matter
what it leaks but no matter what leaks
they will focus on the fact that a leak
took place of course the leaking in
principle is what's bad according to
Donald Trump when it's something against
him but when it's something against his
opponents like Hillary Clinton then the
content in the leaks matters many
discussions about this happening on our
reddit discussion forum I invite you to
visit us there at david pakman.com slash
reddit today's program is made possible
by taga dabbe the hosting specialists
offering a range of flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options as well as custom
server solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
taga dad's web hosting services support
a wide range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and taga dad has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything
you need for total ease-of-use they are
really proud of their team of expert
hosting specialists who are also their
support team 70% of their business comes
from repeat orders and recommendations
with a growing number of people
interested in moving their businesses
and projects to the cloud taga dab is
currently offering our viewers and
listeners a twenty British pound free
credit about twenty four US dollars to
all customers signing up to give you a
chance to try the service this is a
limited availability offer first-come
first-served for viewers and listeners
of the David Pakman show to take
advantage of it go to signup tag adapt
calm /td PS and use the offer code TDPS
20 all one word all lowercase
during account registration